hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
and in this video i just want to do a
message about rent to rent because
is it possible to do no money down deals
yes is it possible to buy properties
using other people's money
yes is it possible to secure rent to
rent using no money
yes is it possible to find a renter and
they need a little bit of money and then
borrow that money
yes all these things are possible all
these things are
simple the same as anything simple the
same as learning to drive
is simple and driving is simple but if
you
mess it up and you don't know what
you're doing are there things that can
go wrong
yes can this cause problems yes can this
cause you to be worse off than you were
potentially yes of course if you do make
a mistake and you lose money
see it as a lesson so i just wanted to
put out a little video about rent to
rent and explain
why i don't think that you should
generally speak in unless you are
really smart unless you're really good
at rent to rent and you've been trained
and you've got
a power team on board i don't think you
should find a rental rent
and then you should ask somebody to fund
that rent to rent deal
and give them a fixed return on
investment so this happens all the time
people find rent to rent deals
and they haven't got any money they're
scammed and they say
oh but they think that this rent to rent
deal if it comes off
it's gonna it's gonna make them a
thousand pounds a month maybe it will
maybe it won't
so in their hope and in in this um
whole cuckoo land because it might not
especially if you
don't know what you're doing and it's
your first one and you've not got good
people around you and you've not got
mentors and trainers
and a lot of people watch maybe my
videos or read a few books and then
suddenly they just go
when they find a rent to rent deal it's
actually not that great and then what
happens is
they they borrow the money from someone
or from or or put it on a credit card
again i'm not saying this is bad if you
know what you're doing but if you don't
know what you're doing then this is
this could be devastating they borrow
the money off someone and then what
happens is this person says oh
okay well how much you're going to give
me and you're so confident this rent
event is going to give you loads of
money
what you do is you say i'll give you
back 15
interest a year which is really high by
the way and then i'll give you your
money back after
a year because you're so confident that
this rent event is going to work
and then what happens is you take this
rent to win deal you borrow five grand
or whatever you need
five six grand off of an investor who's
gonna get
that fixed interest you sign a contract
you guarantee you'll give it to them
you then put that into the rental rate
and then the rental rent goes wrong
the landlord pulls out the um the
tenants
you can't rent it for whatever reason it
goes wrong or you have to give it back
because there's an issue with the the
leasehold the head lease
there's some problem and then it's like
okay what am i going to do now so now
you've got no rent to rent or it's not
making money and now you
have this debt to this investor now
you're five thousand pound down
you end up having to just work really
hard on your typical job
pay the investor back or you tell the
investor what's happened you can't pay
him back and you end up getting taken to
court and sued
it's really really bad so that's what
can happen
and this can happen by the way if you
don't know what you're doing you don't
have the knowledge but there is a
solution
of course there's part of the solution
is to get educated and understand
and one solution is to just do normal
down rental events
so if you know what you're doing you can
do a rental event and you can say to the
landlord you can say
listen i'm gonna give you a guaranteed
rent for five years i'm gonna do this
this this this this but part of the
condition is
i'll pay rent in arrears which means
that you don't pay any upfront rent
and you don't even you don't pay deposit
you can say i'll take deposits off the
tenants
so you don't you don't pay the landlord
any money up front you can lease the
furniture instead of buying it so
there's ways that you can structure a
rent to rent whereby
is pretty much normally down deal but
sometimes you're going to need
money for the deal because sometimes it
might just be a case of well there is a
little bit of money needed here
here and there so do you walk away no do
you raise the finance
probably not what you do if you're if
you're a beginner is instead of
raising the finance because i don't want
to just bring you problems see many
people just give you problems and you're
like ah
oh no and then you'll end up just
working a job until you're 67 and then
you're retiring 40
of what you couldn't afford to live on
in first place after working 40 years
for 40 hours a week so i don't want that
to happen i want to give you a solution
right here here's the solution
instead of borrowing the money from an
investor you ask an investor to
joint venture with you so
what there's a massive difference
between that if an investor
joined ventures with you and this
investor needs to be someone that
understands the industry okay
if they joint venture with you then
there's no risk for you
because if the deal goes bad well it was
their deal as well as your deal
and the joint venture goes like this you
mr joint venture person a you are going
to put the money in any money that's
needed to put down you're going to put
the money in
me the entrepreneur i'm going to find it
manage it set it up and do everything
that needs to be done
we'll go 50 50 on the profits now once
you've done this if it succeeds
awesome you might say but i want a
hundred percent no
because you're skint take your 50 to be
happy
give them their 50 you have your 50 you
can even set up a little company
or that's a whole other video but but
but but then what you're gonna do if it
succeeds is you're gonna put your 50
profits aside and you're gonna let that
grow and then when it grows to five or
six grand then you're gonna do it
yourself
but this time you're gonna have 100 if
it goes bad
that's a problem but at least you're not
going to be left worse off than you were
because if it goes bad it's like okay
well you've lost your time and you might
be disappointed but you've not actually
put any money into it or gone into debt
to do it because you've got a joint
venture on board
so get the knowledge man i honestly
believe it's so important to
go crazy and to be put offers forward
and stuff but i cringe when i hear
stories from estate agents i used to be
in the state agent but honestly
i think here's the i'm teaching people i
have youtube
i have um online trainings i run courses
and i teach people
a legitimate skill which is how to
basically build their
property portfolio as an entrepreneur
and you can start most businesses
without putting any money down so it's
about how to be creative
and i teach that and it works and it
worked for me i started at 17 years old
i had no money
now i'm 29 and i have a very very big
property portfolio and everything i
teach is just everything that i've done
even going on courses i don't tell you
to go on a course when i didn't i did
the same thing
so everything i teach is what i what
what i've done and what i do
but the problem is when i hear a stage
i'm saying stuff like oh this person
walks in the other day and said he was
looking for a no money down rent to rent
i'm like
oh my you don't walk into an estate
agent and say you're looking for a no
money down back to paint like
learn learn how to speak properly learn
what to say
get a business plan write down your
goals
find out what you want tell people what
you want be clear don't be around the
bus but at the same time don't say
i'm looking for a no me down rent to
rent find out what the landlord wants
give it to him
make sure there's a break clause make
sure the contracts are right bring on a
joint venture partner if you haven't got
the finance who knows what they're doing
do it properly but do it so hopefully
i try and get the right balance on my
youtube channel you might have noticed
recently i've
been putting out some of the negative
things that can happen in property my
goal is for you to win in property and i
want to i want you to see the good the
bad and the ugly
but most importantly what i don't want
to do is i don't want to make it so
complicated and hard
that you think i'll forget it i'm not
going to do it and then just and then
just do a job forever because a job is
harder
i've had both i've had a job i've had a
business i've been self-employed i've
been an investor
and i tell you something if you're going
to work hard anyway you might as well
get rich
so i hope you find my youtube channel
helpful i hope you found my videos
helpful
i am going to be running a webinar it's
going to be a free webinar on rent to
rent where i'm going to go through the
whole process of rent to rent
and if you want to join me on that
webinar in the description i'll leave a
little link and you can click on it and
you can join with it it's free to join
there's no charges or cancellation fees
or anything like that
i just want to see you guys win real bad
but i want you to do it properly
i won't take action but the right kind
of action so if you enjoy my channel
please do smash the subscribe button and
turn on the notification bell
and press the like button drop a comment
below let me know what you think of this
video let me know you want to see in the
future
and i'll see you next time thanks so
much